this happened on brew street that's near
the 15 in cheyenne
8 news now reporter madison kimbrough
spoke to police about the incident
joins us live from near where the
shooting took place madison
yeah so you can see behind me it
happened at this office building
right here at 3432
north bruce street you can see in the
window it says happy holidays
now we are told by authorities and then
also when i walked up there
that this is a one love clubhouse we'll
get more into that on what that means in
a second but
at around 4 15 this morning north las
vegas pd received multiple calls
about someone getting shot at this
location on north bruce
street upon arrival
officers located an adult man unknown
age
suffering from at least two gunshot
wounds medical personnel arrived and
transported the victim to umc
where he later died
according to police during the party two
people got into a fight over a gun
a third person stepped in with their own
gun and started shooting
we are told this clubhouse where the
shooting occurred was part of a private
auto club that's what it seems like to
me
while doing a quick search online it
looks like almost
a car enthusiasts club
and motorcycle enthusiasts club
now currently there is a person of
interest to this crime but police
haven't released
further information when i went up there
a couple minutes ago i did see
a huge spread of motorcycles inside we
tried to talk to the people in there but
they did not want to speak to us so we
will of course keep you updated
as more information comes through
reporting live madison kimbrough
8 news now